who's calling today from 949 maybe third
time is the road arm here yes
hey David this is Patrick I'm calling
from Orange County California
hey Patrick what's up hey um first of
all I really love your show I listen
every other day thank y'all I just
wanted to get a quick question from you
how do you feel about the legalization
or like decriminalization of like
suicide and mushrooms magic mushrooms
yeah I know that Denver that Denver does
dealing with that they had actually what
happened with the vote in Denver uh to
be honest I don't know I think it was
just yesterday so I'd have to trigger
okay
yeah uh I think I mean certainly the
decriminalization absolutely absolutely
yes and on legalization I might even
lean towards yes as well on on
psilocybin mm-hmm how far do you go with
like narcotics in general do you think I
have a question about the legal the the
recreational legalization of cocaine
like I'm just I'm sure about that I'm
unsure about recreational heroin I've
seen yeah very good arguments that those
should be decriminalized but not
legalized recreationally so I did a
segment about it where I said it I'm not
taking like a moralistic position it's
just not it's clear to me like with
cannabis recreationally legal absolutely
psilocybin recreationally legal probably
cocaine heroin I'm just unsure yeah it's
kind of a I wouldn't say slippery slope
but it's how do you judge what the
society will turn into if you legalize
what type of drug that's one component
that we could consider sure yeah oh hey
I really appreciate you answering my
call all right very good great to hear
from you that's all the time I have for
today sorry to everybody I didn't get to
but we will take calls again quick break
audience questions coming up next